the best thing that I've learned over
the years when you're writing it and
shooting it and then editing it just
keeps changing each time and then what I
always do and it drives everybody nuts
but it's true as I'll sit down and say
okay okay so we just we just saw the
latest episode of Barry you go to a bar
and you're sitting with your friend and
your friend goes oh you just watched
latest episode of Barry yes and they go
what's it about what do you saying you
know what I mean and it's like well it's
about a guy and like that order in K
that of the the information is how we
should probably lay the story out and
it'll be interesting is they'll tell the
story and it's going smoothly and then
you'll go that's great but you've never
once mentioned Fuchs so we got to go
back and make it so he's he's you can't
talk about it without mentioning him or
you'll you know you'll talk about the
whole thing like that's great but you
never mind once mentioned Barry which
happened season two we had a whole
episode that I wasn't in right and Alec
Berg and I went you're not in the show
you know my favorite episode yeah it's
my favorite episode he goes you're in
two scenes that's the only one I've seen
oh yeah that's the Emmy winner yeah I
thought Henry was buried
I'm Barry people are always like what's
it like working with Henry Winkler and
it really is all about the cake that he
brings to set oh he just brings bundt
cake I'm like Henry you're losing your
mind in this scene and you're on the
verge and he's like and then after that
can I give the the crew the bundt cake
Robert wisdom is gonna scream at you and
make you cry and he's like right right
well I have the coffee in the front okay
right over and he has a story about
everything right over in this corner you
know Gene Charlotte attacked me
or whatever it is you know he wasn't
attacking he was one of the first
celebrities I saw when I came out to LA
with Greg Daniels in 1985 we went to
something and one of the first
celebrities not the but one of the first
celebrities and you have to remember
um you guys are too young but but Happy
Days in the 70s was the biggest thing in
the world and the Fonz was the biggest
part of Happy Days and you know in my
school in my English class there was a
big poster of The Fawns on the wall the
teacher had put it up just to like try
and pacify us he was such a big thing
so I get to La this will calm them down
they still calm them down hey how do we
calm these children down maybe Farrah
Fawcett and they're like yes here's a
picture of Abraham Lincoln
here's one of the Three Stooges no The
Fawns cool
look at them sir we went to some event
and uh I couldn't believe it but it was
everyone was going to their cars and
like this big almost like a station
wagon pulled up that the valley is
brought up a station wagon and it was
raining really hard and the when one of
the windows had been left open and um
Henry Winkler came out to claim the car
and his wife was getting in the car and
he opened up the back seat and he took
like this big Rag and started wiping the
water off the back seat and I thought
what's The Fawns doing yeah he's some
schlub wiping water off the back seat of
a station wagon yeah what happened he
jumped in the car quickly went eight
it is him
no he's the sweetest guy on the planet
very sweet very nice guy and and and so
he's a guy that you can also when you
you know I was I would on set be kind of
overwhelmed or whatever he would always
be like I just want you to know you're
doing a wonderful job and he would walk
away that's sweet you know it's
interesting that
uh my son and I are
such Barry Fanatics that we
last year decided we need to go back and
re-watch them all
this was we did that before the last
season so we went back and watched all
of them again and what struck me was how
there's an arc to the tone of the show
that's very organic it's a compliment
but if you watch the first Berry
secondary third Berry it's
um it's much lighter and then and and
it's almost when you start down this
path
and I'm I was loving it the tone starts
to gradually change
but it's subtle and now if you look at
where we are now you can't believe the
ark you can't believe where you started
which to me is a real achievement yeah
that I mean that kind of was
you know when you're writing it you kind
of start with this kind of
idea that is kind of on bait on the face
of it could be a very kind of glib idea
and then when you try to do it
realistically you kind of move on and
then it's finding it and you go oh this
is like you know this is the tone of the
show and I think there's just some
touchstones I mean one in season one was
when Barry is in the car with his friend
Chris and he has a choice to like kill
him or not and he kills him and there's
no joke after that and I remember being
in the edit and going Allied Berg
directed that episode and we were going
well the next scene is like a comedy
scene you know what do we do to well
let's just put it in there and see what
happens and it didn't hurt anything you
know and it was like oh that's
interesting we can do that so it was a
bit like having some sort of machine
that you went well it's still we're
still afloat you know we're on a boat
and we're trying all these things and we
haven't sunk yet so let's try that you
know we can go in that direction
but a thing I always thought of as we
were moving forward was um the movie
Rosemary's Baby if you watch that movie
starts off very purposely like a Doris
Day movie yep it starts off there's
nothing you know
uh uh overtly creepy about it it's like
a very nice couple buying a place you
know an apartment you know uh and at the
Dakota and it kind of moves forward and
then as it's happening the tone starts
to slowly shift you know in a way and I
so that that's always stuck with me in
that to what you're talking about but
then I don't know about you you've
experienced this too when you're writing
something you're kind of like it's how
you meet people too it's like we're
writing a character and you're meeting
all these characters and it's how you
meet somebody it's kind of superficial
and you have your initial take on them
or impression of them and then as you
hang out with them you start to get to
know them better and they've just become
you know slowly and increasingly more
complicated you know and it's just
trusting that and then also I think the
other thing I'll say is when you're
dealing with murder
it was very hard for me to be funny
about it you know it could be strange
but it was hard for me to
um have someone get you know the Janice
Moss character get killed and then kind
of forget about it and I was like no no
when she dies that's for the whole show
like you can never forget about her
every episode she's mentioned because I
think that's what happens when someone
loses somebody and so you would be in
the writer's room and everybody's going
what was the comedy you know and it was
like no no but we gotta hold on to that
we have to hold on to that and just and
just trust that it'll work but also
is it a comedy why does it have to be a
comedy yeah that's true yeah I get
that's funny you say that because I just
did it but I do bris I just I've been
doing a ton of press so I'm a little
tired but uh so I was the last piece of
press you did literally it was the last
thing you want to know I'm more
impressed you know I have more press
left
oh I've done just about every shitty
thing you can think of like I'm scraping
the bottom of the barrel
they reintroduced the shows that were
canceled I went I went to I just did
Regis I just did regions I just went to
Bonnie Hunt's house
Bonnie let me tell you about Barry and
she said I don't have a show and I was
like listen Katie Couric she doesn't
want to hear all these people
they don't know they don't know me
I said why why didn't you get the
episode
I saw you on Hannity yeah
I was like look look at my look at me
when you talk to somebody
when you talk to a man you look at him
no but but uh but it is a thing you get
a lot of which is uh is this a comedy or
not and it's like ah we're just telling
a story it's so funny because this
season of Barry starts off in this very
dark place
and then I'm not giving anything away
but at one point
uh NoHo Hank is uh with his partner and
they have a cut to him and he's wearing
this hat and these glasses and I lost it
it's such a funny anivers and so to me
this idea that
things can be incredibly dark but then
you can you and to me it makes the funny
much funnier yeah also if it it what we
learned was that as long as it stayed
within that character where you would
say well NoHo Hank this is what he would
wear in Santa Fe yes yeah you know this
is what he would want to wear that's
what he's wearing which we always
thought was very funny so it's always
like when it comes out of honesty it
kind of works and the things that
wouldn't work was when we would I would
you know hand of God you know comedy
nerd try to come in and create something
that wasn't coming organically out of a
situation or the characters and that was
usually the stuff we would lose